[Music]
chuck
i got a new topic for you uh oh
excellent what do you mean uh oh
what's that supposed to mean that means
i'm ready i always that makes you like
you're a little scared
no no for me uh oh doesn't mean scared
i'm like uh oh
like all right you know so i don't use
uh oh properly
okay clearly clearly i'm not using uh oh
in its proper form if someone says oh
something bad is about to happen yeah
you know what i i supply and you know
what i'm gonna have to stop doing that
so uh now i know what the problem is
every time i say uh-oh and people were
like what and i'm like
nothing all right so
consider a few things i want to talk
about life
and well okay yeah it's relevant and
uh on size and life
well um listen the way i see it is this
okay uh you know
size is a preference thing okay and not
all of us
can actually you know be what
some people might have as a preference
and you know why are you looking at me
like that
because why perhaps you've been told
something
about you know uh my ethnicity and maybe
i'm supposed to be
a certain way well it doesn't
necessarily happen that way for every
every person in my in my position and
someone who looks like me we are witness
to chuck digging himself out of a box
that's what that is so here we go
so yeah you you're in a room there
right all right it looks like a hotel
room all right you can walk around on
the floor
okay okay um if there were an aunt
walking around
on the floor it would be doing just what
you're doing absolutely however an aunt
can go to the wall
and then just walk up the wall right how
come you're not walking up the wall
because i'm not spider-man okay that's
all
if i were spider-man i'd be walking up
the wall okay because spider-man is
imitating a spider
yes he is okay but there are no spiders
the size of humans
this is true that can just walk up the
wall correct
all right there's a reason for that
there's a very good reason for it
and has to do with the physics of life
nobody ever talks about it that way
because the biology this
you can talk any biology you want at the
end of the day
physics sets the rules take that
biologist
there's a little smackdown for you you
physics sets the rules even in your
world
physics all right so it all comes down
to this
go ahead chuck okay so
um how strong are your limbs
well the strength of your limbs is
measured
by the cross-sectional area
oh all right so that tells you how big
your muscles are well you're just
embarrassing me on every level today
first we're talking about size now we're
talking about
skinny wrist shanks all right so just
take any part of your body
your legs and your arms take the cross
section and that tells you how big your
muscles are
and when you say have big muscles you're
measuring sort of a
circumference okay right and that's
that's related to the
that's always the way you measure the
circumference of the air okay right
so as you get bigger
your strength will grow as
your the area of your muscles right
cross-sectional area of your muscles
okay however
your weight goes up as the
cube of those dimension dimensions oh my
goodness
i now of course i know your your weight
goes up
but i didn't realize hey wow that's a
lot that's okay
so that's why okay
a 300 pound person
does not look all that much bigger than
a 200 pound person
right okay they're chubbier and they're
big if they could be taller whatever
but if you start increasing depth height
and width
right your volume as your volume
increases so does your mass
but your strength necessary
to sustain that volume and that weight
does not go up in proportion
right so your limbs if you're gonna hold
up
a heavy animal your limbs have to be
much fatter than they would otherwise be
if you were smaller and what are your
heaviest animals on earth
uh your elephant your whale yeah on
earth's surface
the way the the elephant the elephant
how its legs are huge yes
okay they don't have spindly legs no
their legs are
huge to compensate for the fact that
strength only goes up
as the area of their muscles while the
weight is going up as the
volume and volume rapidly outstrips
area okay now you can go the opposite
direction
as you get smaller and smaller and
smaller
your the weight with your volume gets
lower and lower and lower
and the strength of your limbs becomes
better
relative to your body weight that's why
ant can lift
what is it what not only is it why they
can lift
things relative to their body weight
relative to the body weight
okay all right that's not only can they
do that
it's why they can get around with really
skinny legs right
okay yes they have six of them but
they're really skinny compared to the
size of the thickness of their body
because the legs aren't holding up much
weight relative to their own strength
right so and they intermittent fast they
do intermittent fasting too
so is that how that works thank you
thank you
go
wow so you know what you just you just
gave me a really
um stark thought which is
i watched this documentary about this uh
guy who climbed uh
uh the only cliff face that these people
die all the time climbing
without any belly and um
this guy was super skinny
yep yep not not strong like with big
giant muscles but i mean his muscles
when you look at his musculature
this dude was ripped he's ripped but he
doesn't wear very much but he doesn't
weigh much at all correct
correct and that's why in the movie
cliffhanger which involved
rock climbers and mountain climbers it
starred sylvester stallone
who's got all these muscles is like now
every mountain climber
on earth knew that that is not the body
type because he's got muscles where he
does not need them
he's got body mass that is counter
to his ability to support himself right
so
so the point is generally and there's
certain exceptions
depending on environments the smaller
you are
the the less you weigh the thinner your
legs can be and still hold up your
weight
and the bigger you are in mass the
thicker your legs are so rhinoceros
is and hippopotamuses right hippopotami
and and elephants all have
really thick legs because as they got
bigger
uh if they kept their thin legs they
break their legs and that'd be
that's the end of you you get eaten and
that you leave the gene pool
very quickly when that happens okay
all the lions are missing you okay
remember what we used to
none of those elephants with the skinny
legs man
we used to just find them lying around
oh they made such a delicious meal
remember remember those days we were
just
on crutches because they kept breaking
their legs right
so and anyhow so snap so that's why
you don't find very tiny creatures with
really thick legs
that's that so because they don't need
it that's the point
okay so so now that so that's a
important fact number one whales are
different
because they don't weigh anything right
you got to go back to our weight density
and whatever you're about to say
we talk about i think we talked about no
we didn't but they're buoyant because
they're at a certain depth in that
right so they don't they so they don't
have to hold up their own weight that's
why they can get so
big right okay so it doesn't
it's not fair to say how much does that
well weight 400 tons
no it doesn't it weighs zero because it
is neutrally buoyant
in the water and if you bring it onto
the land it will die
because it cannot hold up its own weight
it cannot do anything
in its own way so you cannot say it
weighs that much
because that's not where it lives it
makes so much sense because you've never
seen a beach whale
all right i'm out of here
i'm good i'm good with the land thing i
said i tried the beach i tried to breach
that i'm gonna roll myself back on in
here i'm good i'm
yeah you never saw that you never saw
that so that's so
they don't weigh anything they don't
have to hold up their own weight so
they're really not so everything i'm
describing is sort of
in the air on earth's surface okay all
right
so but i'm not done oh cool not only
that
the laws of physics don't all manifest
equally at all size scales
interesting okay so um
if you're going to drink water you'll
put it in a glass and then you'll
drink it like this right why do you put
it in a glass why don't you just sort of
pour it in front of you
well because it'll flatten out on the
table and you'll make a mess
right okay but suppose i
am an insect again i suppose i'm an ant
does an ant need a vessel in which to
put the water in order for it to drink
no because water beads up there's a bead
of water that does not continue to
spread it could just walk up
and suck the juice right out of the out
of the bead of water until it's gone
okay now the producers and writers
of the movie bug's life knew this
so when the mosquito went to the bar
and ordered a drink and what drink did
the mosquito order
a bloody mary of course
okay so bloody mary i
just i just turned it to my mother i
can't believe you you turn into your
parents that's right turned into my
parents then
oh my god okay sorry
bloody mary o positive okay and so the
bartender
which is another insect i don't remember
what kind has a spigot
pours out a blob of bloody mary and
plunks it down
in front of the mosquito and it's just a
ball
okay held up by surface tension
surface tension is this sort of this
imaginary film that exists on the
surfaces of liquids
that you have to sort of puncture that
in order to fall through
but that's that sort of film actually
contains it
in small enough amounts surface tension
is not strong enough to contain a big
blob of water like this
because gravity wins but when you're
small enough gravity loses against
surface tension super attention wins
they plop this drop of bloody mary in
front of the mosquito
mosquito put in its nose sucked it out
and then
that's that was the end of that scene
this was brilliant and it's in that
movie it's a pixar movie
that phys people who knew physics and
chemistry
writing the script for that movie so
different forces operate when you're
small
than when you are large and so that's
why they have
there's something called is it a jesus
spider a water strider
sometimes called there's a yeah there's
one something that's
that walks on the water swiftly and in
some regions they call it a jesus spider
i think
um anyway because jesus in the bible
walked on water
well except jesus weighs more than the
surface tension
would have held them up so jesus would
have just
sunk without some kind of magic
or spirit or miracle okay right
whereas if you're small enough well
maybe he had just
giant foam sandals we didn't check
it was right he was the first person to
wear the giant foam sandals
and they're just like oh my god jesus
it's the mirror
people misinterpreted it right they were
like hey but go ahead
so so with the so all i'm saying
is that if you're small enough that
surface tension you don't weigh enough
to break the surface tension
so then you can just sort of walk on the
water as some insects do
so my point is size is everything in
this world
and you might say well could you have
something really big
like a life form the size of a galaxy
probably not here's why
because suppose you're that big by the
way the galaxy's 100 000
light years across suppose you you have
your head itches and then you send the
signal to the brain and then it goes to
your finger
and you got to bring your finger up to
scratch your head
well that that took uh that took about
30 million years
it took it's going to take
at least 100 000 years to get your arm
to your head
moving at the speed of light and you're
probably not moving at the speed of
light
so so you just you're not going to be
able to respond to stimulus the way
life needs to in order to thrive in an
environment
so there's certain sizes above which
are not realistic so physics contains
the largest and the small and by the way
you can't be so small
that quantum physics prevents your
molecules from
from binding you can't be smaller than
the sizes of molecules
right because what are you at that point
okay if m if molecules comprise life
you can't be life that's smaller than a
molecule it's just not there's no
so so the chemistry and physics contain
all the realms in which you will find
biology and that's just the beginning of
it i'm giving you the basics of it
where where that's the entry level sort
of size and life 101.
uh so so there you have it so so so
spider-man he's got the powers of a
spider no
not if he's that size no doesn't no he
doesn't no he doesn't
right no he doesn't he can't
no he basically just has the powers of a
really
uh really good rock climber rocklin
yes that's about it
that's about it all right we got we got
to go there
good to have you always a pleasure neil
degrasse tyson signing off
[Music]
you